CBS News has confirmed that later today
Pentagon officials will give President
Trump military options for any possible
retaliation against Iran for its alleged
role in the strike on Saudi oil
facilities in Lee is in Saudi Arabia
where he's getting our first up-close
look at some of the damage done in that
attack this is the damage that the Saudi
government wants to show us they say it
helps build their case against Iran
that's about as close as they're going
to let us get officials say though in
the early morning hours of Saturday for
cruise missiles came screaming in from
the north direction of Iran and hit this
facility while the United States says
they're looking at all options short of
going to war they are building an
international coalition against Iran to
isolate to that country a team of UN
investigators is also here they're
looking at that damage and also going
over the remnants of those drones and
those missiles to independently go
through that evidence to verify it but
while Iran still denies responsibility
next week
Iranian officials are going to New York
for the UN General Assembly where
they'll likely face some tough questions
for CBS this morning
Ian Lee at the Christ oil facility in
Saudi Arabia